throughout the day on saturday small
groups of people arrived to pay their
respects on clapham common
near the bandstand close to the spot
where sarah everard was last seen
so how did this quiet dignified
spectacle
descend into this
we've analyzed video footage from that
afternoon and evening
giving insight into some of the key
moments
by four o'clock we see the first signs
that numbers are swelling here
with around 200 people gathered near the
bandstand
around half past five and a steady
stream of people
are now heading here it's clear that
although the original vigil was
cancelled
many are determined to be here it is a
conflict
between all of us and the state
15 minutes later it's obvious not
everyone here
is solely focused on just having a vigil
[Applause]
but although there were people here from
different groups some with different
agendas
the bulk of the crowd were clearly here
to take part in a vigil for sarah
by six o'clock the crowd had grown to
more than 500
in response the police presence is also
slowly increasing
as a minute silence is held in memory of
sarah everard
at this point a key moment as a local
councillor can be heard urging people to
begin leaving
so thank you for coming this evening we
do all need to disperse
obviously peacefully and everything else
but thank you all very much for joining
us
in an aerial image we've highlighted
small pockets of police officers
mainly on the edges of the crowd
scotland yards say
it's at this point they were trying to
persuade people to leave
almost half an hour later with no
discernible change in the crowd size
a police liaison officer makes a direct
appeal to people to leave
nobody here is socially distanced
and we're asking people to go home
[Applause]
few here appear to be listening from 6
30
another potentially pivotal moment as
police commanders decide to move more
officers
up onto the bandstand the atmosphere has
shifted
things are much more this is no longer a
ritual
too many people in one place
that's dangerous within 20 minutes
the bandstand is almost surrounded by
officers
20 minutes after that addressing the
crowd
patsy stevenson now an iconic figure
after the pictures of her subsequent
arrest were flashed around the world
here she's urging the crowd to resist
the calls to disperse
the police
[Applause]
just after twenty past seven another key
moment in our sequence of events
as police take the decision to start
removing people from the front of the
bandstand
including patsy stevenson
[Applause]
it's at this point that the tensions
here spill over
into scuffles and arrests the image of
patsy stevenson
penned to the ground by male officers
united all sides of the political
spectrum
and beyond in a shared sense of alarm
by 8 pm the crowd around the band stand
is beginning to disperse
but an angry group can be seen following
officers
as they take those arrested back to
their vans
it is far from the dignified evening of
reflection
the original organizers had planned
the video timeline of events captures
the key moments of escalation
that led to the scenes of disorder but
it'll be up to the independent inquiry
to determine whether that crucial police
decision
to move in and disperse people was the
correct course of action
mark white sky news